hello and welcome to this video playing
CD w-what b3 I don't see that too often
hmm well if I've cannot be that bad here
right I try this c3 okay it's still a
fairly healthy development they have to
set up against the English with Bishop
c5 now he's got c 3 player okay this is
not very ambitious looking but not bad
for what I quite clearly you can do that
yeah so
yeah how to do this i mean if I've need
some protection
yeah then this is a little bit
uncomfortable with the with the King
they only seven age five here 20 will go
h6 in this case mmm they don't like this
so much my cannot go be should be 6a
unfortunately and c6 he has night to d6
yeah I probably have to have to give him
the bishop if he wants like 96 Queen c7
King c7 let him take Adam not not happy
about it but I probably have to
otherwise I don't see how are
coordinating coordinating here should be
395 should be okay oh really now that
that doesn't strike me as being so
dangerous it's bishop d for a movie and
Bishop t4 and potentially checking I
don't know
yeah it's quite useless to discuss I
have to play anyway I have to play that
anyway so here check check King L
everyone I have some Trixie I have some
tricks going on here let's do this first
oh I'm sure to be four but should be 293
and 93 doesn't really really do all that
much Bishop the tool you can take night
before i could play night before yeah if
he takes is mated but it looks extremely
weird yeah maybe maybe still I mean
maybe still I appreciably to coming
weird if it's not if it's not I will do
something against the major like this
okay um I can take on a tool but night
situ we open so Bishop teatro maybe but
this is serious right we will take on a
to where if you place rookie one I will
ever do that
yep that sets looks better what's going
on here if the rook t4i move here just
to get active here my time I have spent
too much time here
yes I mean ah ok interesting should be
three would be nice but it's not
possible if i go here i have a potential
check now one there's this ship's you
three i mean i can my hand can play the
move anyway night a torx it work d too
but those pieces look like they get
trapped they really do come on now I to
attempt it I have a potential check now
sometimes if you move the king and III I
will take maybe this works and time
morning that at least keeps me keeps me
the material I came it's very draw much
of course but one one thing I can do I
can play it rather quickly in this
position to subscribe this is good but
particularly difficult to play
okay let's do this let's see what Paul
do I want yeah probably the ape on the a
pawn should be the pass am not sure
maybe I have some some winning chances
here not totally sure most likely is the
draw of course but I can go up to the
two maybe yes a fortress a king he Rab
it's probably the fortress but it's okay
i can try without doing any anything
risky or whatever yeah this is the
fortress draw our third game drive
cannot do anything i also really don't
lose risk the risk on time because i can
i can pre move 50 moose am that said
said stool yeah huh it was shame but i
didn't i don't think i could do much
there maybe probably doesn't matter
really what I do
you can always go there and yeah we can
we can get this set up no matter what so
let's have a quick look that was not
super exciting and physically Jim this
is so it's not very cat challenging
let's say to take one in five but maybe
yeah I felt in the game that I may be a
little bit uncomfortable here here
should be fine yeah yeah he's got him
getting in some cap some trouble yeah
now I'm the engine wants to take the
pond now the way I I did later yeah
probably I mean I should try to come to
prevent opposite colored bishop so what
the engine is giving hear this and this
is certainly better but I had well what
I had to had in mind is that this is
easy to play I mean and with the time
situation the ng6 is probably a bit
tougher but it's still a draw i think
it's it's just not not much l technical
or it says some some way that i should
something that I can do here roughly
here to prevent this blockade later
they're probably not i think the the
drawing probability is extremely high
here ok guys thanks for watching